[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من قناه الجزيره اتفقوا وزراء
فقط الاوروبيون على تحديد السقف للسعر
الغاز وعلى اله التنفيذ فقد نائب رئيس
الوزراء تشيكين الاتفاق سيفعل بشكل اليا
اذا
استمرغاز لمده ثلاثه ايام في تجاوز حاجز
180 يورو لكل ميجا ويت في الساعه اضاف ان
تسعيره سيكون بريرا لان الهدفه هو ضمانه
الامدادات واستقرار الاسواق الماليه وقال
الكريم ان القراره هجوم على اليه تحديد
السوق للسعر ووصفه بغير مقبول واكد انه
سيتخذ القرار المناسب بشانه
على الرئيس الروسي مؤتمر الصحفيه مع نظيره
البيلاروسيه فيكتور
لوشنكو ان شاء مجال دفاعيا موحد بين
البلدين مشيرا الى ان موسكو
ستواصلان اجراءات تدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه وقد نفر كريم للان يكون الهدفه
من وراء زيارته
بيلاروسيا هو اشراق في العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
جربه
الاسلحه خاصه انظمه الدفاع الجوي
والمساعده في تسريع قرارات الشرك بهذا
الشعب
صوتت لجنه التحقيق باقتحام الكونجرس
الامريكي لصالحه رفع توصيات لوزاره العدل
باجراء تحقيق الجنائي مع الرئيس السابق
جورج ترامب تتمثل التهم بعرقله عمل
الكونجرس والتامر بهدف الاحتياله على
الحكومه الامريكيه والتامر لتقديم تصريحات
كاذبه والتمرد وقد انهت اللجنه تحقيقها
الموسع الذي امتد لنحو عامل و نصف العام
ومن المقرره ينشر التقرير النهائي
الاربعاء المقبل قال رئيس الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات في تونس فاروق معسكر
ان نسبه الاقبال في الانتخابات التشريعيه
بلغت 11.22 في المئه واكد ان الهيئه رصدت
نحو 1800 مخالفه
هذا المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الاقبال الضعيف على صناديق الاقتراع خلال
الانتخابات البرلمانيه التونسيه هيعكس
حاجه الحكومه الى الانخراط في عمليه اكثر
شمولا لتوسيع نطاق المشاركه السياسيه
هذا وقال مركزه كارتر الدولي لمراقبه
الانتخابات الى الانتخابات التونسيه تفتقر
الى الشرعيه وان الاجراءات الرئاسيه لم
تنجح في توحيد البلاد واضاف ان نسبه
الاقبال الضعيفه على التصويت في
الانتخابات التشريعيه التونسيه تشير الى
ان خريطه الطريق الرئاسيه التي نفذها
الرئيس سعيد لم تنجح في توحيد البلاد
انتهى المشاهدين هذا
[موسيقى]